hot breath and you've done it all like
you've released five albums and you've
done it all yourself
yeah you've you've really kind of
created your own success in many ways
right
yeah you know i did all my own i'm gonna
make a
a six album now i think
but yeah i do all myself my my wife and
i my wife's very creative
she's one of the best writers in the
business one of the best comics in the
business
hands down just had a big article in new
york times
writes directs i mean she's way more
versatile than me
a hundred times more and we create a lot
of our own projects
our own shows we do shows in moon tower
montreal shows that we created
and and no one's no one's throwing
anything
at you in this business once in a blue
moon
someone they'll get something here and
there a friend will help him or a
younger guy or
a very talented actor comic so you gotta
really you got a lot of competition and
you gotta create your own stuff
mm-hmm
you